talk about it in more detail joining us
the joint General Secretary of the
National Education Union Kevin Courtney
hello to Mr Courtney thanks for joining
us on the program this morning uh what
impact will this these three days of
strikes have on schools
well lots of schools will be affected
and many children will have to remain at
home and I want to say to UK we
sincerely regret the disruption to
children's education and to parents
working and home lives today but we
think we're taking action for a high
moral purpose to try and get the
government to invest in this generation
of children who are being ignored by
this government so there will be
disruption on the three days of actions
at its strike today in the North
tomorrow in the Midlands on Thursday in
the South and we regret that disruption
but we want government to invest in this
generation of children
impact on exam students
no
well I mean it's the same the same point
being made we regret that disruption now
teachers will work really hard with
those exam classes they want their
children to do well in the exams that
are coming up but we make the point that
there are GCSE chemistry classes without
teachers who are qualified in chemistry
there are GCSE maths classes that are
being taught without teachers who are
qualified in maths and that is impacting
on those children exams preparation
every day and we're trying to get
government to invest in order to
overcome those problems
[Music]
okay so does that mean that exam
students will be impacted oh
they certainly will I mean many schools
the exam classes will be in school but
there will be schools where they're out
there will be schools where those
children are out of school if they're up
to school I think they should be doing
uh exam preparation that's what they
could do this afternoon if they're not
coming on our demonstration but my point
to you okay is that their education has
been disrupted every day by the fact
that we haven't got enough teachers in
our schools in our qualified teachers we
don't have enough permanent teachers
there are temporary teachers doing their
best but children are being disrupted
every single day and that's because the
government has let teacher Recruitment
and Retention for the such perilous
levels there have been pay cuts there
have been pay Rises less than inflation
almost every year since this government
was elected in 2010 and they are
carrying on now the pay rise last
September was five percent when
inflation was 12 percent the pay rise
they're forecasting for this September
is three percent and forecast of
inflation are 10 on RPA for this
September even though it's starting to
fall or six percent on CPI and those
paid cuts are leading to a situation
where we don't have enough teachers in
our schools and in addition when they
make pay Rises they often don't fund
them properly so that schools have to
make cuts to fund the pay Rises and
that's why our members are taking a
stand and they see themselves and I
agree with them taking a stand for the
children they teach they are standing up
for Education they are standing up for
their profession and they are trying to
make sure that this government invests
in this generation of children the
generation of children hits so hard by
covid we're trying to make sure the
government invests in that generation of
children
Mr Courtney um
for me if you would please reported that
your joint General Secretary missed a
very important meeting with the
education ceremony because she was
enjoying the Norwegian Fields
um is that right
we were fully represented at that
meeting I was at that meeting Mary had a
long booked uh cruise on a over
half-term holiday that she booked with a
friend many years a couple of years
before and we agreed she could go to
that because I would be at the meeting
with the Secretary of State what they
this is Mischief making by the
department for Education it is not a way
to will to build trust in the
negotiations because what they haven't
told you is that a minister Nick Gibb
was also not at that meeting because he
was on a half-term break why do they
tell you one part of that and not the
other part it's just Mischief making on
their part and it damages the prospect
of reaching an agreement because they
they destroy trust in the negotiation
process
because Nick Gibbs not asking teachers
to go on strike and your joints General
Secretary is probably
well we're not asking members to go on
strike our members have voted in
overwhelming numbers to go on strike
this government really doesn't like the
fact that working people are allowed to
take strike action but they are taking
strike action it's the most effective
strike action we've had I think since
the 1980s in terms of the number of
people involved in it the fact that 50
000 people have joined our Union fifty
thousand people have joined our Union
since we announced our ballot results on
January the 16th tells you that teachers
it's not us it's not me and Mary making
people go on strike teachers have had
enough they want the government to
invest in them invest in their
profession and invest in the education
of the children in our schools
okay and
we said these strikes um going on for I
think three days I'm sure we'll chat
again or perhaps there will be a deal
before that I'm sure that so many
students and teachers live in hope that
that's the case but for now thank you
for joining us as always thank you
absolutely